today on our show Oh much new you ain't
gonna be able to handle it thick dick
worth of news right here on today's fat
man on Batman
[Music]
Roger Batman Batman I'm Kevin Smith Mark
Barnard a ok man here in the fat cave
listen the dulcet tones of a band in a
distance you might hear the familiar to
tones of the band from television
Greg Grunberg band made up of people
who've been on television so their ear
Singh right in the next room so you
might hear them throughout the show but
[ __ ] that we got important [ __ ] to talk
about
plays on the first off welcome back it's
been a while
no I are upping you into Sunday when
some bands will have even doing editing
the LA time being at the Los Angeles
Times robbing his big newspaper [ __ ] on
the fan club was not a some ants
although editing a bunch of stories
about Sunday I was interviewing people
um you know there's no pressure cuz I
had no movie like last year I had a
movie and whoo-whoo-whoo uncomfy trip on
the way go on up the hill be like we got
a movie we got a movie go definitely
like we had a movie we had a look so
this year it was like no stress man no
mess I've talked to people at movies and
spending bad it was kind of cool I had
the last time I was to mention there was
a lot of there was a lot of this but I
will admit this people come into the
room being like what year are we talking
to you like kind of like what happened
like why what was this what didn't you
nevermind let's just talk aren't you
supposed to be some like young
attractive female reporter that I'm
talking [ __ ] I don't think doesn't look
I think the look they were giving me was
not you're not hot and young we were
going like don't you have another job
and I'm like this is my job um yeah
who's the job now it was interesting
they were there was honestly they all
seemed kind of relief they come through
the door be like oh like he's one of us
and you know I made it fun I was never
like like I had Kristen Stewart there
and you know I was like Benson which I
guess nobody would cuz there's about
nine years old but that morning there'd
been a story had broken about Trump had
written tweets about her
patenting and so like when she came in
you know like I could have been like
habit and [ __ ] Trump tweet me but I'm
like she's a director she here with a
short film she's an artist talk about
her art excuse me so at one point I went
off page and didn't talk about her film
kinda it was tangental but there was an
article that was published that she had
co-authored a paper on artificial
intelligence and it was related to her
film so you know I talked about that but
like I was like I'm looking at that
Trump thing a variety they were like hey
man what about the drugs we had that
like I saw that all over the news yeah
blew up so then I was like oh I should
have [ __ ] planned for the Trump [ __ ]
but they were like no it's good needed
because she was like she said you were a
favorite interview of the whole festival
and you know I was like lost because I
didn't [ __ ] go hey man let's talk
about talking [ __ ] has nothing to do
with your short film and it sure felt
strong she's gonna win an award yeah
she's gonna win awards for directing one
day she's got a good eye she's like very
lyrical I like I was impressed for you
know a short flick
maybe she's also one of those kids who
grew up on set and grew up on the best
sets you know like at what would she
Fincher dude yeah like a lobby man old
doing pancreas and the shorts very
visual is visually oriented it's not
like a lot of like hardcore performance
there's performance but it's not a lot
of dialogue right like maybe a [ __ ]
Fistful of dialogue in the whole thing
but beautiful to look at so anyway yeah
I talked to a lot of this kid so a lot
of them seem relieved that I wasn't
sitting there going like what about the
[ __ ] dirty [ __ ] you know is just like
integrate being a [ __ ] Sunday you
know you've been there you've been there
before you acted like you've been able
to see them like I had been or would
want to be true anyway that was [ __ ]
then now we're back in the fact cave and
we've got [ __ ] news goddammit things
happen a lot of [ __ ] going on yeah [ __ ]
so we better address it all starting
with the biggie mmm the big tasty if you
will
uh we have a title and we've added like
to the new Star Wars movie but you don't
have a thing until we say you have a
thing that we learned on the title so
for some people like I'm the best engine
of the way for you guys to bring to do
guess what Star Wars is called the new
Star Wars Episode eight it's called the
last Jedi there you go now there's been
a lot of debate on the Internet's about
women are Jedi without an S is also
plural does the last I mean more than
one Jedi oh is it Jedi's with an S a
Jedi you like what like like what
animals are plural while sounding
singular sheep deer
oh my god it's a game show moose look at
that it's true it is one of those words
that could the last moose the Star Wars
all right so they can you know for I
when I first heard the title I was like
well they must want us to think it's
Luke look maybe it's right now and what
you're saying is at least why not both
why not a little surf and turf and let's
also not forget that that Luke Skywalker
trained kylo Ren before he went bad
oh so maybe they redeem him and [ __ ]
maybe well [ __ ] there's no reason he
[ __ ] killed Han Solo you know get to
kill him Chewie go right in the [ __ ]
face a face melting shot from a laser
crossbow at 6 inches away that's the
only Redemption that character gets [ __ ]
you kylo Ren Simon your name then closer
yes I love Ben they better not redeem
him he's got to burn some [ __ ] just
got a burn mark no redemption if you can
redeem Darth Vader whoo let's remember
we told a bunch of younglings yeah yes
it was actually like the Hitler of the
galaxy and at the end he kind of went
soft so he did like that that's what
those perfect movies are about but we
have
yeah but it's so far Carlos killed one
dude yeah but it was pretty important
and he killed Max von Sydow as well
Thank You Ming the Merciless know him so
he kills you probably ringing the bell
for kylo Ren every time people want to
be like that bad guy he killed [ __ ]
Max von Sydow and Han Solo is what also
killed his father
patricide is a difficult thing to come
back to his father because like in some
cases you could support that sort of
thing but he killed one of our friends
this part of a [ __ ] drunkle our drunk
uncle uncle you were always happy to see
the one who was like what's this and he
pulled the [ __ ] 50 out for me on your
ear
Wow yeah way better uncles and I did and
I read that but I would have it he'd be
like oh hello we get the spaceship and
go flying around with a dog I happy
here's a shiny nickel thanks it's 2010
which is an angle putting any of mine to
the last Jedi last year I could be any
three of those this is the Rian Johnson
in the episode a picture
I bet usually if Dad that out in the
world I'm sure you none of them like you
never want to be the person that flips
the last joke man I think there's a
quote from deja really who knew what
we're talking about it on the set during
production and she had to like everybody
sit on it for like six months I know it
is so they gave her a script no title on
I think so I think it's one of those
like marketing and go figure that yeah
you just go shoot up the movie yeah
we'll figure out what's up episode 8
it's got a title writers get to work
well [ __ ] very good a fairly stuff
out later Kathy Kennedy yeah like at the
Getty impression of what we're gonna
look at okay so [ __ ] everything's
hunky-dory in Star Wars land when's this
picture coming December when we can see
a trailer any minute now
uh yeah my guess is like big movie is
Beauty and the Beast beauty and that be
is that trailer I did looks exactly like
the car to accept but the beast is now a
weird awful bestiality monster I mean
well she had sex with this thing right
like we know that that's part of the
stones you they I didn't get that out of
that what happened in the cartoon
I broke I don't remember that well but
his [ __ ] lipstick poverty was like
music
seems like be my guest be my guest
put my lipstick to the test and she was
like goodbye I remember that at all
little things I want to a [ __ ] better
movie and that's why I never you give me
one of them Disney remakes because of my
can we put dog lipstick in but like you
know they kiss like you know they're
making out example [ __ ] dude she's
kissing a giant dog yeah but I kissed my
little dog all the time I'm lucky if
only you were a person we'd run away
together are you understand me yeah like
a thing that was two dimensional
animation run into three dimensions
weird it's it's a little odd do you
think that you think that matters for
anybody except you that can be a thing I
got some people who can go through the
Bob Zemeckis movie because they were
like well little baby baby tell you
something man tell me so I'm in a game
Call of Duty game isn't uh like
literally scare me into the game Raven
the Redwoods called DLC game for those
who are gamers and even if you're not a
gamer if you've ever wanted to [ __ ]
watch me die in a video game over and
over again he ate it tough that much
Raven the Redwoods is you and it's me
scanning and wearing this outfit and
[ __ ] like that but I went to a
livestream at infinity ward though the
people that made the game and I watched
Lee the guy who wrote the game play the
game and for an hour so we're standing
there and I'm watching the game and I'm
making comments shows you having a good
time but like to the end of the hour
dude uh listen I was just like I feel
hot [ __ ] faint and I feel like a
little bit nauseous but I mean anything
so I was like and I just hungry what's
going on and then I was like to the
off-camera photos it can you clear
password or man eyes like I might have
to go right out to the bathroom that was
done and then we were two minutes from
the end of the thing and finally I was
like I'm sorry and I took off my
headphones and went to the bevit like I
made it outside the door and I was
[ __ ] dizzy and like it took me a
minute to walk three feet to the
bathroom door got in the bathroom sat
down on a chair in the front part of the
bath
not like where the stall the yarn over
and then [ __ ] had to laid down like
and I'm sitting there going I'm having a
heart attack heart attack feels like I'm
46 oh god I gave up milk what more do
you want
damn you totally and I'm laying on the
bathroom floor the people Infinity Ward
are stopping people going in the
bathroom [ __ ] and finally I threw up but
I hadn't eaten anything that was just a
br thing you were doing or is it just I
didn't know the [ __ ] going on I threw
up and [ __ ] it was just all water and
then I thought 100 cent like thousand
percent better oh my god what am i doing
on the bathroom floor and I got up and
they told me they're like the game what
do you need they're like you don't play
much game I said why I mean I would
never play as fast as he was really good
leave it like he wrote the game and [ __ ]
so you know I imagine I would go a lot
slower and [ __ ] poke poke around and
stuff they said yeah it happens there's
a percentage people that like it motion
sickness go build yourself up and
pollens and stuff like that
that never happened to me and so I
looked it up online do you know what
motion sickness is it is when the body
thinks it has been poisoned really is
that [ __ ] nuts
the reason you throw up like you think
about it it's something to do with
visual and you want to be like oh your
equilibrium basically the body is
reacting as if it's been poisoned that's
why you throw up I had nothing in my
stomach are throwing up water but I felt
better because the body is just like we
are get this poison out of us it's the
only way we must be feeling like this
because they don't [ __ ] get it
because we're you know when the [ __ ]
body evolved from [ __ ] troglodytes to
us video games one card to the [ __ ]
acclaimed embargoes this is weird I felt
like an old man for the first time I was
just like I got sick looking at the
Keita games yeah the brain is an
interesting thing sorry
yeah like I was listening to a podcast
and we're talking about what actually
happens when the experience - I'll do
okay yeah what is it
it's that there's a there's a blip in
the matrix we because it is a glitch in
the matrix or it's also that the brain
secretes when you recognize something
yes your brain is accessing the memories
in the weird render way to the brain
and then it's triggering like a
familiarity response if you like oh I
recognize that person on that thing and
it's giving you the oh okay you should
respond as if you know it deja vu is a
slight malfunction of the cement a
familiarity response like the button is
getting pressed without the right
trigger for it so you just like Oh
clearly this is the thing I've done
before even though you can absolutely
even though you haven't yeah I like the
matrix explanation a little better I
mean it's it's way more red and I hate
when they do mystify the mysterious I
hate science religion bargain it it is
that mean I guess that makes sense I
always like to believe I love the idea
of like yeah I have done this before
I'm retracing steps Liz I just saw the
mirror universe one of the looping yes
but instead really she's your green
being Brooklyn was nukid yeah kind of um
there goes all the romance of magical
and also midi-chlorians yeah well
everybody loves that
midi-chlorians so MN production began on
star wars red cup which is the
standalone Han Solo movie first shot
they're calling it red cup I was on the
cloud board because so uh-huh all those
are the boys who did the lego movie I'm
Miller Lord I'll follow them off a
[ __ ] cliff the lego movie is bright
they did something else too they
produced a last-minute earth show or
they did a comedy a couple of 21 Jump
Street right funny really they didn't
they do but I love your movies a thing
of beauty so beautiful yeah so there's
gonna be [ __ ] Fanta yeah but do you
think we'll see Lando lose the Falcon we
have to really have to like if you're
gonna make this movie you've got to do
that cuz you got to see a castle run you
got a few moves we've been talkin not to
say that this is a paint-by-numbers
picture no but there's numbers I
absolutely wanted there's some notes
they better hit like you know they
better play some of our [ __ ]
favorites while they're doing they don't
have any shot they can't sit don't be
like no we'll tell that story in
the movies [ __ ] you tell it now you
don't know how to [ __ ] it yeah
sad coolest code don't play your [ __ ]
new [ __ ] okay good for Star Wars yeah as
always good for us what's good for Star
Wars it's distributed raw sweet ones was
adorable because it said Han first shot
instead of Han shot first those [ __ ]
guys and I kept reading it the wrong way
because I wanted to
that's [ __ ] cute oh yeah and the huge
it's cute I feel left out now having a
good time on that [ __ ] Han Solo move
what is alright man uh dune is happening
again we had it once before David Lynch
did it and it was excellent
it's the best version of doom there ever
been [ __ ] fantastic they did a TV
version on Syfy and movie by five
aggregates i Skype I like a four-hour
miniseries a bit of sequel to it Jason
loves again yeah yes I loved it it was
like cuckoo dude dude took 20 hours long
as like that ain't do is two hours long
David Lynch dick I look at him but
people that like the book say that the
miniseries was a lot closer it is but it
doesn't have any of the weird [ __ ]
magic of the David Lynch version all I
see is in the tradies I want to kill
your wounds
haha your skin is like a treasure Baba
the sleepers awake on I shut up here
fear is the mind killer here's a novella
very Shaunie my name is a killing yeah
oh yeah who is an amazing word talk it's
good um but boy it went right in the
[ __ ] hey really the Howard the doc
Ishtar [ __ ] whatever what are the
reasons Yoko's there's a [ __ ] movies
back then man but talking was it reached
for the stars the movie the David Lynch
did instead of directing we turn to the
Jedi yep and the world is all the richer
for anyway they're going to remake it as
a feature yeah our man Denny Z news hot
also the rival
that's what I could say his name then he
didn't use the guy that did arrival
which is called man yeah man he did
Sicario just a car and he did prisoners
yes and he's doing Blade Runner
20:49 right on yeah so he's taking his
stab at Frank Herbert's third astok
[ __ ] book so he did the blade
runner's to a dune he likes the eighties
he likes the 82 like the sci-fi I'm all
about this guy I can't wait I'm [ __ ]
all for it man if anybody's gonna touch
dune again and [ __ ]
I'll see what this guy does because a
rival was yeah I mean although part of
me really wants dune as a TV show like
it has a long form I should be a Netflix
or Nagle yeah like there's no reason or
the problem with that David Lynch movie
they said was like some people like I'm
aloft because doing it thick is it day
everything as it doesn't dick so you
know it would be helpful to spread that
info not but yeah I give you the Game of
Thrones version of doing where like six
years of just palace intrigue superhero
fighting and giant [ __ ] dick worms
and shipped out maces and all the
awesome the spice must blow okay so
that's good news that's awesome
and the other good news department and
you do yet teri hatcher yeah who okay
Supergirl fan hi Supergirl episode last
week well I'm heading up to Supergirl
again next week another episode and in
that episode Miz teri hatcher will be
featured Lois Lane herself Lois from
Lois and Clark : the New Adventures of
Superman the 90s version of Superman
remember that [ __ ] poster man with
her yet like that was like the poster of
the 90 yeah just like her like topless
the Drake in the kids of Kate nothing
amazing
so of course Desperate Housewives of
course they're real and they're
spectacular from Seinfeld and Teri
Hatcher's goddamn TV legend but she's
going to be on Supergirl
in a mishit playing a mystery villain
ustream bad first mystery to some mark
not to me and you know it is yeah can
you tell me later
yeah I'll tell you later all right can't
share it cuz I'll get [ __ ] no look
your tricycle be like [ __ ] you [ __ ]
hit me right in the nuts just garage
maybe nothing absolutely [ __ ] greg
berlanti behind me with a garage Christ
burning and [ __ ] Berlin she wanted me
gone you should not you fat baby
yeah now we gotta do this oh my god just
be quiet just let it go let it go quite
do smells you never [ __ ] with the
Berlanti let me find you when you live
let me come back honey wide open oh are
you turned into like a friend I know
music re oh he went off the director
movie mr. Bernanke yeah this right yeah
and kids I think he's like cuz you've
got two big movies on deck right he got
I saw the Little Shop of Horrors remake
you know huh and then he's the Booster
Gold mr. gold was well written by our
man Zack Stemmons accents who wrote this
week's episode flash I saw that dude
ended with a [ __ ] killer a lot
spoilers if you haven't watched flash
yet five four three two one
Barry going like I'm not gonna say virus
you were gonna say virus to Wally
[ __ ] ah hero already he realizes he
can't get fast enough so he's just like
why am I trying we got the kid Kid Flash
he'll say his sister and then something
tells me I'm no writer but maybe iris
will save herself she'll need saving
although she is held by [ __ ] saboteur
sorry sure did look at me he loves me
just holding something to do with Oswald
your old Nathanael loving very good
point see okay so teri hatcher how
[ __ ] cool is that exact they've got
Lois and Clark now I like them as any
pulling Magli Kreisberg is all about
that rice burger merle aunty do they
like [ __ ] they give they pay homage
indeed homage your we get first come
play with us now it's very very cool so
I get to fool around with her as and
actually found said not fool around but
like hey let's go play Jason Mewes just
directed her in a movie really in this
movie is directed sure yeah she will
have been during one of the few people
in the world who's been directed by both
Jay and she should get a t-shirt teri
hatcher it's [ __ ] exciting Jenna
League that ant wait going to be up
there going to
like action but I was really happy
everyone applauded and the dog laughing
she's real and she's spectacular this is
the this is hot news that broke last
week indeed hot old news will you uh
will you terminate a fan course who's
not a terminator fan they [ __ ] with time
time travel movies are so [ __ ]
amazing they've turned into time travel
series everybody do Tom Joe we all love
the notion time job particularly this
year so this Terminator now more never
feels wonky because after tomato Genesis
which nobody seemed to like in band wise
this isn't like this that movie that
movie feelings he'll get mad James
Cameron is now returning to the fold
who has water come every time they make
a Terminator movie that he doesn't
directly there's always the James
Cameron has given movies bluffing he sat
down with a filmmaker we did with the
agenda the last one we were like saw he
was like look this is if I was going to
keep doing it this is what I would have
done like it's the go visit the Pope
having kissed the ring and then
everybody's fine but now they're giving
it back to him now they give it a back
jump and apparently he's going to
oversee a bright young filmmaker who are
quite fans of here a youngster a young
[ __ ] I'm pretty sure he's giving young
kids a chance
what about 46 year old like my duck mark
apparently you're not old enough my
friend why because it's our name to
Miller Kim Miller getting their hair
whenever Tim Miller the wunderkind
behind Deadshot and what are your key on
a future who I think is like
50-something
yeah the 150 years old he wrote me to be
like hi he's gonna be direct in
Terminator Cameron's producing it yes
and I'm buying tickets for it for you
for me for them everybody everybody
everybody needs somebody everybody was
somebody's love I'm going to low we've
got the hands flat someone love there's
just one note anyway I don't know
there's just one [ __ ] you were there I
was told there yeah we need him want one
more practice wrong very
Batman talent you let her tell her I'm
gonna coming to do something I did that
good oh yeah I did just come on in
history class like I did a report on the
Cotton Club and it was an oral report
and one of the like points is over for I
literally played Minnie the moocher all
the way through it's like a three-minute
aah and miss Clark was this tree teacher
like loves it maybe do the report for a
few classes because she loved that funk
going on the road I got a good grade
because the cab County we're going now
to the fifth grade and everything about
the report was predicated on that movie
I didn't I mean never been a harlem own
years old i don't know anything about
here we go media exactly central not
even South Jersey
where's Harlem I was like a man and then
in 1920 Richard Gere went to the shop
where he ran into Diane Lane who would
later play Superman's mother Martha you
all know what happens when Batman and
Superman find out that Martha their
mother's name in 1982 a white guy made a
movie showing other white people about a
black jack without alright guys oh it's
Richard Gere welcome for Coppola that's
is Ford Coppola hey so nothing should
possibly your coffee historically that's
a good [ __ ] oh you know was it what's
his name Bob Hoskins plays Owney Madden
good movie pretty bit ugly like Gregory
Hines is amazing with his brother it
woman won't dance they both [ __ ] tap
together to touch him sure they split up
and then they come together mmm at the
end or am I good glad to take it back
I'm gonna go watch cotton club do it I'm
going to watch Blues Brothers go back to
the 80s uh um [ __ ] it let's just get
both go watch the Goldbergs
they do the eighties every week and they
do it well yeah some Tim Miller
going back to the future to the Past the
Terminator they're assembling one of
those now in vogue writers rooms of like
science fiction authors and writers with
a bunch people together we're budget
we've got a room like how do we fix this
and end this I think this is supposed to
be a reboot and a conclusion
ridiculous go to the trouble of hey we
rebooted it and goodbye you know who
knows but it makes a billion dollars
this is not the egg no I mean but they
keep trying to find a way to do this
without Schwarzenegger because so so
that code for he's going to be in it
again I mean I he was the last one and
they had as good a reason as you're
going to get for old Schwarzenegger to
still be a terminator there's only so
many ways you can skim that these think
Cameron's like look with all the respect
I'm happy with what people did the [ __ ]
it we're going right back to to but this
movie is the official sequel to
Terminator 2 they could absolutely just
wipe it clean cuz I only he's ever
really acknowledged anything else as
direct lineage back to to you get landed
Edward Furlong back do you guys Linda
Hamilton back choc sided Michael Biehn
doesn't look that bad that does dad dad
dad dad dad dad dead yet but it doesn't
have to be like next week after Trent t2
it just has to be like three and four
and general Isis none of that happened
the continuity goes Terminator
Terminator 2 and this new one I've
always wanted to do like a short film
Myles Bennett Dyson's bad day like this
woke up in the morning like I have a
great day any obvious kisses why honey
today I'm gonna figure out a I thank you
guys like we almost cracked it right
what's happening downstairs what I don't
write back okay helicopter in the house
what why is she shooting people in my
house
did you pick an exhibit that makes me
wanna watch t2 now I forgot about that
whole scene it's really good it really
holds up yeah it is it is a remake of t1
but in a way that you don't cool yeah
all right so you got that to be excited
for yeah don't die yet I'm gonna have
now we got new stuff and then last but
not least MN news weather Aquaman is
getting closer and closer to [ __ ]
jumping in the water
it is the DC movie they seem to be
actually making yeah things are looking
up for Aquaman nothing fishy here now
they're talking about it they got
Michael tied man to play his mother
promising young actress from Australia
ah yeah I've seen her and stuff wait a
second what mother mmm so what the
origin story of like she left them on
the lighthouse steps made that you're
doing that they could be doing that
flashback [ __ ] probably in jail alive
right you know out of the comics yeah
could be in this one are we muttering we
chose I'm not sure because we have yeah
we got a veneer kids not going to speak
with conviction because we were wrong so
what they got Mira they got him they got
her his mom by and now they've also
added back Manta heavy pronounce and
Yaya Abdul Mateen hi I'm doing the team
the Secchia from the ghetto visit to
their here's a tune you saw the gift I
get you to get you know this is I do
know they knew this that he was there
the impresario of the nightclub slash
drug dealer who dances like nobody's
[ __ ] business like good [ __ ] like
great disco so I'm gonna be in it so I'm
gonna Andy here I mean if he if he
pretends to be like one point to like
break it down and come on bring it if
that would be amazing
do the fish he's like Justin Hammer
usually I'm dad and just starts dancing
they need to bring him back
Oh like why not bring him back we saw in
the show I should put him out in like
the Netflix shows you know it is always
busy Sam Rockwell's still yes but I'm
character day officer he's like is this
is this a bird of rushing good
why the bird okay yeah like that's a
losing point we haven't said block Mon
ah hold on whatever thought I'd see live
action Black Manta you know I'm telling
who's directing this James Wan listen to
me Jimmy Wan I'm telling you right now
you want to remain number one in my
heart
he'd better wear - goofy [ __ ] outfit
he better wear it don't come up with
some modernization [ __ ] and I want a
giant [ __ ] head
that giant [ __ ] eyes sleek black body
you got a swimmer's body perhaps or
dancers Bob you kill him no bet but he'd
better have that [ __ ] do not
compromise on the helmet read my lips
can I get an amen do not compromise on
black mantas helmet testify anything
else you can add a mother you could
[ __ ] you don't even have to look like
Aquaman anymore no orange shirt but god
damn it you just make just make this
little fat boys dreams come true
show me Black Manta Ivan speak to the
[ __ ] bro bro bro bro bro through that
[ __ ] that character has the potential to
be the [ __ ] baddest villain in movie
history the look of a Darth Vader but
underwater and there's way more water
than there's earth and you can send a
shark after because Aquaman said it's a
black man to be like and cut the head
off a [ __ ] shark if I don't show you
how bad a theist like a shark comes out
I mean [ __ ] grabs it by the gills and
he's just like this is what I think of
your powers Kareem he's [ __ ] rips it
open from the guild you would respect
the [ __ ] out of it if I don't see
somebody punch a shot [ __ ] style I'm
gonna be upset I want a lot of shark
punch in the face they ought to call it
Aquaman : show Aquaman 2 : shark punches
careful Aquaman why just go right at you
alright that's [ __ ] great news Black
Manta badass laughing nut I'll hold it
so you know give
- that is [ __ ] faut none could be
finer than black Mantha in your jaw iris
in the morning there it is folks that's
all [ __ ] news your current now you did
it even though some of that shit's like
weeks old your current now go out in the
world these are telling it was just
sweep up it was they were gathering I
mean again it was it was a potpourri you
may have known the news before but you
knew what we knew we knew dit for you we
knew it knew it but good dude bomb rage
okay that's it this week man The Fatman
Batman come back and another episode man
[ __ ] him right here the fat cave I've
been Kevin's man and I've been his
friend mark McGregor business here in
the fat cave same bat-time same
bat-channel
vodkas calm or youtube.com slash Kevin
Smith
[Music]
you